let's not forget that this dude came in  even came in and everybody came against  him the Mead like he got he hit the  Beehive he got stung by everybody the  media and it was all set up it was all  Russia was all what kind of attitude  would you have if you're a boss yeah  yeah yeah yeah yeah and you came in and  you know what you said your fake news  and because of that look at CNN it's  gone because he pointed them out all  those all the Pelosi all the everybody  came on him bro he fought back I  wouldn't trust anybody and I'd be an  [ __ ] if I was him too so what do you  expect I don't agree with the going  after uh the Santas but bro it's a fight  if you're number one you want to be  number one you're talking the gloves  come out